I'm not paying $4 40 oh I know I think
that's you know about 250 and I think -
I think - 50 40 oh I'm - a tunnel by
Laura hey I'm Shaquille Brad it take
from hey guys I'm miles I'm Glenn what's
up this Sean
lights out Larry minutes Desmond came
here from the Los Angeles chargers my
name is chase with Amex and this is
build your squad as you can see we've
got a lot of extremely talented
polythene caliber players it's gonna be
very tough for me I think I'm gonna go
with patching behold we're going to
home-school gotta go with Patrick I'll
have to go with Pat Pat Mahone he passed
my house I'm an my Hans only three
that's a guarantee Len Dawson low key
looks like the dude from Charlie the
Chocolate Factory
this was that reason well that dude he's
got the golden ticket bro he's got the
golden ticket we're sending them to
Hollywood let's go I think I'm going to
morals I think he's really underrated I
thought he's a great player I think I
can go out and win with you ain't got no
running back go Jamaal Charles my dollar
for Jamaal Charles I play with your
macho's I played against Jamaal Charles
I know he the real deal let's go Marcus
Allen we need somebody to run the ball I
got to get the team for cheap I gotta go
with the great running back right there
Marcus Allen another Trojan as well and
Hall of Famer my next big gonna be Jerry
Rice there's Jerry Rice why wouldn't you
got to spend big bucks on good players
I'm gonna go for the best of the best
I'm picking Jerry Rice here unbelievable
it made just a great play he's gonna go
out make plays for Patrick mahomes here
this this is my wild card just looking
here I'm going myrn Hanks just cuz I
want to see the wall I want to see that
the wall dude I'm gonna get Ronnie Lott
off the board if we go come down he'll
make the big kids it set the tone for
the rest of the team all right Ronnie
Lott and supporting the great 49er as
well oh wait if I could get two of them
I could I don't would do that that's $12
Ronnie Lots the man Oh Ronnie Lott
oh wait no I got nothing ready like I
don't know I got no time take it off
Ronnie lot that's a big I've wrote a I
wrote a check that my mouth can't cash
I'm ahead uh I'm gonna go with Charmin
though cuz share ameba consistent
lockdown for a long time you know what I
lower it you sure I mean I got two
dollars so that richest army
I'm gonna have to incorporate a lot of
trick plays in my offense I think
especially with what we got here so we
got five minutes squad I think we're
gonna do some some really trick stuff
I'm gonna have to go to my man Alex
Smith Serbian we're gonna top it off -
quarterback action never seen it coming
they won't know how to expect it double
quarterback passes let's go so the
reason why is I think defense begins
with the safeties and the defensive line
those are the most important positions
in my opinion that make great defense
hey hey the nine is a yeah y'all I see
why y'all back in the Superbowl now cuz
with defense like our guy now remind me
it is defense with Patrick Willis and in
a that's the right way to go this is the
best squad because I covered all phases
of the game right touching my homes
Jerry Rice can go out make a little
place well I think that duo it's a great
duo it might be a little bit better than
the Joe Montana I Steve young Jerry Rice
- OH
you know maybe we'll see you know
without without roster here Jamaal
Charles we're doing halfback screens
maybe let's go